and we turn to moscow now
u.s basketball star brittany greiner is
on trial on the charge of transportation
of drugs the hearing began today four
months after she was first arrested
while traveling to play basketball in
russia greiner was detained at a moscow
area airport after cannabis oil was
allegedly found in her luggage in
february the drug charges grinder faces
carry a sentence of up to 10 years
well for more on this let's bring in
philip hebner from dw sports philip give
us a break then of what happened when in
this case so this case all began on the
17th of february that is when griner was
traveling to russia to play basketball
there and that is when custom agents
discovered that there was allegedly
cannabis oil in her vape cartridges that
she had brought um today the court has
actually um said or the prosecution has
said how much quantity of cannabis oil
was allegedly found we're talking about
0.7 grams
0.7 grams 0.7 grams and that faces
potentially 10 years in prison in russia
so that's what we're dealing with it
took the u.s government um two months
after she was initially detained
to declare her as wrongfully detained um
so a very long time as well um the
preliminary hearing took place on the
29th of june her detention was then
extended another six months
and there was also a court gate given
that is today the first of july and
today the hearing has started there is
no press allowed in the courtroom at the
time being during the hearing and also
the
the lawyer has said of brittany um
griner that it's approximately a
two-month time period that they're
looking at until a verdict is reached
talk about the verdict uh what are the
chances of a verdict that goes in favor
those are very likely those chances are
very very small the acquittal rate in
the russian justice system is under one
percent um so that also speaks for
itself
there's also talks that russian
officials often plant evidence such as
narcotics on people that they're trying
to detain for political reasons as such
the kremlin has said that this is not a
political ordeal however looking at the
facts it seems quite the opposite that
greiner is indeed a political pawn in
this situation
there is one
perhaps scenario that
might see her free sooner than later and
that is a prisoner exchange
russian media have said that there are
ongoing talks between the biden
administration on the one hand and
russian government um about an exchange
that would um see griner um and victor
about being exchanged for one another
victor boud is an arms dealer
who has the nickname the merchant of
death
and he has been imprisoned in the u.s in
the year 2008 for a total of 25 years
when asked about this u.s officials
declined to comment on it so they have
neither confirmed or denied
now what are the reactions like
regarding her situation and also the
start of the trial so um a petition has
been signed by over 300 000 people at
this point um for the u.s government to
take more consequent actions um in order
to bring her back home to the u.s
there's also a big outcry by fans by
family by friends of course but people
are still
quite furious that this is not something
that has been on public display and that
the government isn't doing more there's
also big talks about equal pay regarding
men and women um so grinder in context
um is being paid 230 000 um to play in
the wnba for one season um over in
russia it is up to a million and it is
after tax so that is the reason why she
was there in the first place so that is
why people argue had she been paid
fairly in the wnba this whole case would
have never happened